what's the difference between film
markets and film festivals
markets are generally um not open to the
public they're for buyers they're for
industry
executives only so you're getting buyers
from around the world which are
acquisition people
and you know tv executives that type of
thing who are looking for product to
acquire
and then you have sellers which are
primarily distributors
and studios and that type of thing who
are selling product and so a market
would be a place where the two would
converge
and it wouldn't be open to the public
you have to have credentials to register
in one of those in a market
a festival and the big ones are obvious
i mean can has a festival and a market
at the same time
um so they run parallel um
so it's a lot of big festivals also have
markets that run parallel everybody
thinks they're just festivals the public
thinks they're festivals but the
professionals know there's markets
um but there's like a lot of markets
that are just markets like the american
film market is just a market it's not a
film festival so there's no the public
can't attend it
they can't register for it they can't go
to see any films
a film festival is designed for
filmmakers to showcase their movies to
the public
so the public's obviously invited and
encouraged to come and watch as many
independent movies as part or whatever
movies are showcased there
um and it's a chance for a you know a
filmmaker to
one celebrate their movie um you know
because they made this great thing and
they want to and to see it in front of
an audience
usually for the first time and a real
audience as opposed to you know family
and friends and film you know they're
the guys who are on the cruise
so that's really good and do a q a and
get some feedback on the movie
that's what a film festival is really
good for for filmmakers
to get real third party
um usually friendly by the way because
people go to film festivals are usually
friendly to independent films
so it's not as critical as if you
released your film in the theaters and
the critics you know took it apart
that's a little bit you know more
difficult but so a festival is good in
that way
my my sort of beef with festivals is two
things one is
they're curated really tightly and you
know i believe that festivals make most
of their money from
from submission fees i mean somewhere
between fifty and a hundred dollars for
most festivals to if you're gonna submit
a feature
i mean i've submitted to many many many
festivals so i know
and um you know you it's like college
admissions you know you
like you you add it up you know like
sundance i think got
something like 30 000 submissions last
year for a hundred dollars each
so that's pretty good revenue just for
submissions
and uh i don't know if they even need to
screen any of the films
so remember only they're only going to
accept 300 films
so they're going to accept one percent
of what their submissions are and that's
not their fault everybody wants to
get in there right but it's expensive to
submit
especially when you're doing multiple
festivals and chances are you're not
going to get in
so i have a little bit of a beef with
that it's almost like
next time around like you know i don't
submit to festivals usually anymore
because
the the other because the other reason
is is when you do get in
the screenings sometimes aren't very
well attended
the festivals are you know designed for
some of the bigger films and if you're
not a bigger film
unless you are generating the audience
and you know if you're in its city that
you know is you're not your
local city how are you going to generate
audience you don't know anybody
you're not going to spend a lot of money
on advertising it the festival's
supposed to do that
so you can go to a screening and have
you know five or ten people there
and you're expecting you know a hundred
or two or three hundred and this big q a
and everything like that and
you know it's usually often not the case
no no sometimes it is
and you're excited and the other thing
is
you don't get any revenue from your
screenings like you know say 300 people
come to your screening and they all paid
15 to come the festival gets it all
that's
the deal now sometimes a festival will
pay for you to attend
if you're you know a good-sized name
director or something like that or
whatever
um but since that's nice but often they
don't anymore because they can't afford
it
so and the last thing is you know
i mean it's just about a celebration of
art and filmmaking
the festivals there's really no business
there it cost you to go
cost you to submit you have fun doing it
and talking other filmmakers and
everything like that but that's it i
mean
you're not really going to get
distribution the odd time maybe somebody
will talk to you but
about it or something like that so it's
not what people say
and and chances of getting into the big
festivals is far and few between
so the festivals serve a perfect a
purpose in terms of celebrating the art
of film
but i don't think they serve much of a
purpose in terms of generating revenue
yeah i think if you're going for that
reason i think that it's you can weigh
do i want to spend the money do i want
to spend the money to travel there
yeah what about people who want the
laurels for their film website yeah
that's that's also nice that's fun
you know so it's nice to win an award i
mean you feel good your ego gets stroked
a little bit plus you know it does help
in marketing your film at least
it was recognized by somebody else um
it's not tremendously
important it doesn't hurt it doesn't
hurt but it's not i mean you see films
that have
15 laurels on them or whatever and it's
still a tough sell
yeah you know sometimes i say i used to
say this more and i shouldn't really say
it but
when i was a buyer like in distribution
an acquisition executive
um i would attend lots of festivals also
right because you know you want to be on
the you want to see the films before
anybody else sees them so you go to lots
of festivals watch lots of films
and sometimes i would walk out of a film
in a festival and
the audience you know would depending on
the type of audience it was
sometimes when a movie's really really
really popular in a festival
it almost means that it's not
commercially viable to go into the
mainstream
it's a festival film and it's designed
for that eclectic festival crowd
and um sometimes it's the kiss of death
that it it's festivalgoers don't really
like commercially viable films they
don't like what they call these
gum standard you know predictable movies
they like something more eclectic and
more artistic
so when they love it it's almost like
it's not commercial enough to go
into regular distribution not always
but you know a lot of acquisition people
know
that there is a difference between a
very successful festival film and a very
successful commercial film
like most real big hollywood blockbuster
movies
they go to festivals because that's
because there's the stars and everybody
wants to see the stars and they use them
as a as a launch pad
but i mean they're not artistic and
eclectic enough
for the film festival crowd
the only reason they go there is because
they they use them as you know this
publicity stunt
but um a lot of them wouldn't even
bother with the festival crowd because
um it's the commercial crowd it's the
ticket buying crowd that they really
care about
that's fascinating and are those those
aren't really cinephiles
those are more people that are going
after or before dinner
well look at the the biggest movies are
you know are the action
sci-fi superhero would you ever would a
superhero movie ever go to a festival
i mean other than a superhero festival
you know there are some superhero
festivals
you know comic-con has a film you know
okay like
would would a superhero movie ever show
at sundance
hopefully not because that would be you
know challenge the integrity of the
sundance film festival
why would a superhero there's no
artistic merit but there's a lot of
commercial merit to it tons of it
and that's going to be the number one
blockbuster movie of the season
but yet they would never stick it into
festivals because
it's the wrong message right unless it
was a very eclectic
superhero but if it was it likely
wouldn't be successful
commercially that's true because the
people who go to those movies aren't the
people who go to festivals
there are some crossovers i happen to be
one of them
but most people are either commercial
you know moviegoers for mainstream
kind of thoughtless you know action
stuff or they're very eclectic
and want a little more depth and art and
you know and thought
you